today we're going to be speaking with
Bob zeidman who's the creator of the
field of software forensics the founder
of several high-tech firms author of
textbooks and screenplays novels a
high-stakes poker player in Vegas and
also the guy we mentioned who I guess we
could say won the prove Mike wrong
challenge which was The Challenge from
my pillow CEO Mike Lindell known to many
of us simply as pillow almost like
Madonna
um where he offered up five million
dollars to anyone that could prove that
the data he claimed showed China
interfered with the 2020 presidential
election was not proving that Bob you
you proved that essentially and now you
are in the process of if I understand
attempting to collect this five million
dollar prize which a court has said is
due to you if that's the latest I've
read
yes David thanks for having me on the
show and that's correct technically it
was an arbitration but it was binding
arbitration uh three arbitrators made
that decision you know and one thing I
think sometimes isn't always clear I'll
just say this is that uh you know the
the contest was not to prove that there
was no fraud but it was actually broader
than that that the data didn't even have
anything to do with the 2020 election
and you know I've interviewed Mike
pillow a number of times and he always
says listen I'll send you the data and
then you and of course I I don't know
what I would do with it because I'm not
a cyber guy as he says but he never
sends the data first question is where
did you actually get the data that was
meant to be analyzed
so he provided it indirectly he had a
team of people who uh gave it to a bunch
of experts he invited a bunch of experts
supposedly we were all vetted so we
couldn't come to this Symposium that he
held about almost two years ago in Sioux
Falls South Dakota you couldn't come
unless you were vetted as an expert and
then he he gave us the data but at the
arbitration there were a lot of excuses
for why I uh well why it wasn't evident
that this was election data let me put
it that way I mean he said it was
election data but there were a lot of uh
excuses that he didn't give us the whole
data because of National Security issues
because he was afraid of hacking because
he thought that China or somebody was
threatening him uh that it was encrypted
decoded uh modified
so but these these these claims as silly
as they are they do seem to go to
Lindell really does believe this stuff
this isn't a joke for him because this
is something people often ask me since
I've spoken to him a couple of times do
I think he's kidding or do I think he
believes this stuff he does seem to
believe this stuff
yeah so that was a big question all the
experts had that question I can say we
as far as I know unanimously decided
this was not election data I was the one
person who figured out what it actually
was and wrote up a detailed report and
submitted it
but you know the question was was Mike
Bamboozled or was he bamboozling people
yes but he seems to be a True Believer
but the only thing is
any rational person at this point would
know the data's fake but Mike has
basically fired or insulted or
ostracized to anyone who's come to him
including people on his team who've said
that it's fake data so the the data that
was provided what was it what was it
data about what was the the general area
that it pointed to
well there were a number of files that
we got I got five files the first day
and or seven files the first day I
forget now and four files a second it
wasn't a whole lot of files but one of
you know some were PDFs showing generic
voting machine processes uh but the
inter the more interesting ones is we
got a bunch of files that contain what
are called hex data but it was viewable
hex data and so I translated it I got
the idea to translate it to actual
binary data and the way I would describe
that is if you got a bunch of files that
had written out in English language
words
1254 61 and then you translated those to
the actual numbers you know that that's
equivalent to what I did then I took
those files Tran and I noticed that they
were old-fashioned because I've been in
this business for a while old-fashioned
word processing documents so I put them
in a word processor Microsoft Word and
lo and behold what came up were one file
was a table thousands of numbers that
were just numbers I mean just a table of
numbers that didn't mean anything
and the other files were thousands of
pages in one case of gibberish as if
someone had just sat there for hours
typing typing typing then reverse the
process I just did to make it look like
sophisticated computer data so some of
that there's not even really a reason to
think it relates to elections at all
never mind an American election
right no it definitely didn't although
again at arbitration was what was
fascinating is different members of
either Lindell and different members of
lindell's team would come up with
excuses like the gibberish was really
encrypted data that they had purposely
encrypted or China had encrypted or you
know depending on who was talking that I
wasn't smart enough to see it but the
problem was they never they never
demonstrated what it really was they
said oh it's just sophisticated
encrypted data and their excuse was well
we don't have to tell you what it is
because zeidman it was his job to do it
if if he wanted to claim the five
million dollars and the arbitrators
basically if you read their decision
they said even lindell's team couldn't
demonstrate what this was other than
gibberish I'm curious whether as as news
broke of your involvement in this and
the arbitration decision about the 5
million did did you start getting
threats from people or angry messages
because it seems hard to do anything
these days without someone being
absolutely Furious did the did any of
the Believers try to contact you or
threaten you
so that's an interesting question so
first of all you know I'm a I'm a
republican conservative uh I've I've
sudden people who were not so happy with
me in the past couple years I do a lot
of writing on political and social
issues suddenly we're friendly and
telling me what a great job I did but I
have to say even the conservatives the
vast majority of them were thankful some
of them believe that Lindell is hurting
Trump and hurting the Republicans and I
can tell you about that in a minute if
you want but the other thing I'll say is
I've gotten like two or three
threatening emails or Twitter messages
nothing that I take seriously mostly
people say they hate me I'm a Trader
sure but but I went to a conservative
conference a very with some very you
know strong conservatives and even uh
people who advise Trump
and at first I didn't want to mention
what I've done
but it came out and the vast majority of
them shook my hand and thanked me for
what I'd done and a few of them started
questioning why did you do this and I
read this and I heard Lindell and when I
talked to them by the end of the
conference without exception all of them
thanked me interesting now you met you
mentioned that your your uh conservative
you voted for Trump twice right
yeah yeah I did I can tell you that the
first time I you know I don't without
going into detail I did not like Trump
I've followed his business practices and
I've had some problems I've you know in
a very very tiny scale I've done
business with his businesses and I
didn't
find his practices ethical but I thought
it was uh but I really didn't trust
Hillary Clinton and I thought the
Republicans would keep an eye on Trump
and the Democrats would not keep tabs on
Hillary
um did you find that that's the way it
played out
yeah you know it's it's difficult to say
so because when Trump ran there was a
lot of Republican opposition to him yeah
and of course there were the never
trumpers but with Hillary the Democratic
party really universally supported her
as what I saw
um now
you know Trump has basically made this
effort to take control of the Republican
party which I don't like because I think
it's all about him and not about
ideology anymore so I'm I voted for him
again reluctantly the second time but
I'm hoping to have a third option uh
neither Republican or Democrat uh if
it's Trump V Biden I really don't like
either candidate so I'm hoping there'll
be a third uh option that's interesting
so have would you say that you've
suffered under the first two years of
Biden in a way that makes you think I've
really got to get someone else in there
you know I do I I think that Biden you
know Biden was always a middle of the
road
person you know politically until he ran
for president this time and it just
seems like a lot of uh far-left policies
are being implemented or at least
being given uh you know the okay from
the White House really now that's
interesting to me this is super because
I would love for Biden to be far left
I don't see him as being that way I'm
curious what would be a policy that you
see as far left that was implemented
what I mostly see is that well first of
all I don't like the spending bills that
he's uh implemented so I'm a member of
an organization called No Labels which
brings together Republicans and
Democrats I'm familiar with it okay and
so the problem solvers caucus of no
labels in Congress helped pass the first
budget uh bill which was in December of
2022 I believe and then but then Biden
passed his other one which was a lot
more spending on programs I don't like
are you talking about the inflation
reduction act here yes yes okay so I
mean I don't like that I think we're
we're really you know we've gone way
over budget
um
you know we're going to break the debt
ceiling obviously uh I really don't like
all that government spending but also
although you know me you know well first
of all I think there are a lot of things
I think to pull out of in Afghanistan
was horrific we lost more people in that
pull out than we had I think in the past
year in Afghanistan
um I don't like enabling the Taliban in
Afghanistan I don't like the Border
policy we've had more illegal
immigration and then we've had I think
in American history how do you know that
um you know I can't quote sources
offhand but I have researched it so one
thing I do is I really try to look into
I I publish articles and I really try to
do the research to find these numbers
before I uh talk about them yeah well
you know I mean I'm not trying to play
gotcha and really I mean this is just
interesting to me really you're here to
talk about the the Mike pillow stuff but
what's interesting to me is clearly
you're a smart guy and you're
technologically inclined and you sort of
understand how we figure out whether
something is true but like when you say
the Biden spending the rate at which the
debt has grown
slowed down under Biden it's still
growing right we're talking about the
difference between debt and deficit of
course the debt is still growing under
Biden but a little more slowly than
under Trump you'd think a guy like you
who clearly is so fact-oriented would
say hey you know what I I don't like it
but it is better than what we were
seeing under Trump is that fair
well
you know I've I've heard those arguments
before and the problem is even
Republicans have are have been bad on
spending sure that's an issue for me and
I think that politicians in general
uh the best they can they've ever done
is reduce the increase in the deficit
but it's still a dangerously increasing
deficit in my mind sure I mean I'd love
to see uh politicians get in and
Congress represent in the presidency
that could actually cut programs look I
I'm willing I'm a republican who's
willing to cut spending on the military
because although I think our military
needs to be strong it also needs to
spend efficiently sure and just throwing
more money at it and this is a problem
that I see like you know I'll criticize
the Republicans here
the Republicans have to go into an
election if they want to win saying
we're going to spend more money on the
military but in reality I'd love to see
them say we're going to spend less money
on the military for more efficient
operations I mean and by the way I could
I could have another show I sued the US
government for fraud
um because I uncovered fraud it's a
longer story but it was well but that's
I mean that's interesting without
getting into that your view on the
military is not one I expect to hear
from any presidential Republican
candidate even if they believe it
because it wouldn't be politically
viable to say it question for you are
you sort of a little bit concerned about
the degree to which the quote anti-woke
platform is taking over the Republican
party or do you like that
well I like that oh you do I know I know
we disagree on that but you know
something
I can say I've written about this so
um and I'll put it in my personal
perspective I'm Jewish and I even
criticized Jewish groups that are just I
understand them they want they want to
eliminate anti-Semitism which is a great
cause
but in doing so there's this race to be
the world's greatest or the country's
greatest victim and I think this
victimhood mentality is increasing the
racial conflict
in the country and I don't know how to
get away from it because each group I
think looks at another group and says
well that group is getting money and
they're getting publicity and so we need
to outspend them and outdo them get more
attention so that we get more you know
attention for our issues so if the
victimhood stuff isn't appealing when
Trump says he was treated more unfairly
than Lincoln who was shot dead in the
head you're not huge on that I'm
guessing no look Trump says you know and
I'm gonna I have some friends who I have
one in particular who's probably not
going to speak to me anymore but Trump's
is incredibly childish stuff yeah I
really you know it's scary because I'll
tell you in the four years he was in
office I generally liked his policies
but but the problem is he doesn't know
how to run a country and bring us
together true and and he's very very
divisive he's very childish and the
other thing is the you know I hope you
can appreciate this he he likes Gavin
Newsom who is ideologically should be on
the opposite end of the political
Spectrum but I think that's an issue
Trump likes people not and dislikes
people not based on their ideology or
principles but based on whether they
treat him nicely absolutely correct
absolutely correct Bob last thing in the
in the few moments we have on the five
million bucks do you expect to collect
it
no I'm pretty sure that Lindell is going
to lose his cases with dominion and
smartmatic and I think he's going to be
bankrupt and you know if I see anything
it'll be Pennies on the dollar all right
all right we've been speaking with Bob
zeidman who uh he he fought pillow and
he won but we will see where the money
lands Bob I really appreciate your time
today okay thanks David